this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History and
I'm host of star talk radio welcome back
to star talk radio and it's fighting all
these air molecules like what's up with
that we win Dark Matter I could ask what
it is and my best answer is we haven't a
clue we don't know what it is we look
out in the universe
and 85% of all the gravity that's out
there has some mysterious unknown source
we add up all the stars the galaxies the
planets the Comets the black holes the
dark clouds everything out there that we
can see touch smell or taste and it
doesn't add up
to give us the gravity that we see
operating in this universe so really we
should be calling it the dark force
because we don't know if it's made of
matter it could be a profound misnomer
sending people off in thought directions
that might not really be the right path
so dark matter is just simply what we
call this thing about which we know
nothing responsible for 85% of the
gravity of the cosmos we've known about
dark matter since the 1930s
back then it was called missing mass
that's what was called because yeah
there's got to be some mass where is it
we can't find it it's got to be here
somewhere
because we got the gravity if you have
the gravity you got to have the mass
mass and gravity go together it's really
dark gravity actually we shouldn't call
it anything we should call it Fred
something that has no meaning because we
don't know what it is to call it but it
has been oh it is the longest standing
unsolved problem in modern astrophysics
you